it's been nine years since Israel began
the 51 day war on Gaza it called
Operation protective edge by the end
more than 2200 Palestinians were killed
the vast majority civilians on the
Israeli side 73 people were killed 67 of
them soldiers this densely populated
tiny strip of land that's been called an
open-air prison saw a level of
destruction that was unprecedented so
one year on how is Gaza doing the short
answer not well
Elia has dr. Saba no FINA 6-tier withou
Abner home if you are elected dammit
what a super shit when a when a Phoebe I
wanna Fisher sent a model in horrible
armor when I want to hide a cliff
there's a healthy learn Belarusian an
old episode wanna see Phyllis not gettin
sobbing with how to believe in her
- jet hub life in Gaza is pretty much
hopeless for the 1.8 million people who
live there they're walled in by the
Israeli army to the north and east the
Israeli Navy to the West and the
Egyptian army to the south
people aren't allowed to leave and few
can go in this siege has meant that less
than 1% of the construction materials
needed for rebuilding has been allowed
in 100,000 Palestinians remain homeless
after 18,000 homes were either destroyed
or severely damaged at this rate it
would take 100 years for Gaza to be
rebuilt assuming there aren't any more
Wars and the billions of dollars in aid
pledged by foreign governments have for
the most part remained well pledges the
economy is in shambles exports are
virtually banned and imports are very
limited according to the World Bank Gaza
has the highest unemployment rate in the
world
some people have resorted to selling the
rubble of their destroyed homes to make
a bit of money poverty is so widespread
that nearly 80% of the population needs
aid or food assistance just to get by
then there are only emotionally
shattered causes children
most of them have never been able to
leave and have now endured three wars in
six years in last year's war some 551
kids were killed in Gaza and more than
3,400 were injured and even though the
war is technically over their trauma
isn't three and four kids show signs of
severe emotional distress including
regular bedwetting and nightmares so
given all the lives lost and home
schools and hospitals destroyed who's
been held accountable no one in some
instances the Israeli military has
investigated itself and then cleared
itself of any wrongdoing this includes
the attack that killed four young boys
playing soccer on the beach more
recently a UN report found that both
Israel and Palestinian militant groups
may have committed war crimes that
report is headed to the International
Criminal Court and a case might be
brought against the Israeli leadership
but in terms of accountability in the
short term there's not much reason to be
optimistic meanwhile causes residents
are living amid the rubble and despair
wondering how much more they'll have to
endure
Israel's military offensive in Gaza
continues and the devastation is only
increasing you might be wondering what
that huge is real climate